[Music]
blinded by the light this is why disco
died now to the movie that everyone is
talking about crazy rich Asians it's
based on the widely popular best-selling
book and at last night's Hollywood
premiere it was also about crazy rich
fashion this ralphing Russo Couture and
Lorraine Schwartz need these diamonds
for me did Lorraine give you a price tag
on a couple of anelia awkwafina's Reem
Acra gown had a huge ball skirt they
needed some hand what's the most
expensive thing you're wearing tonight
my earrings I think like $300 well I'm
wearing Giorgio Armani put to a pot you
should look at this crazy rich Asian
wash because 1.8 million Michele were
her own high-end jewelry in the movie
and the engagement ring Constance wears
is actually Michelle's personal piece
other gyms were loaned by high-end
jewelers like Bulgari and showcar we had
security guards on set protecting the
gyms there was a lot of expensive stuff
on sets those security anything you
wanted to take home for your wife or
yourself if you could we have there was
like hangers worth of supercars they
were like diamonds I gotta watch and I
was about it on screen the Stars where
designers like Marchesa Stella McCartney
Elie Saab and do your and Ralph Lauren
sent 30 dresses you got to wear some
amazing pieces in the movie have a
Cinderella moment what was your favorite
piece and did you wish you could take
anything home with you
yeah there was this Christian Dior dress
that I wore in the makeover scenes that
was really unique and elegant and I
loved it I begged for it they said no
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]